bonjour christian jacob bonjour nous
avons évoqué naturellement la campagne
présidentielle mais d'abord un mot sur
cette interview de ligue et veyran
accordée à nos confrères du parisien il
évoque la menace nucléaire dans le
conflit en ukraine il répond à une
question et il explique que la france a
à ces diodes pour couvrir tous les
besoins de la population est ce que
cette phrase vous suffit est-ce que vous
avez des doutes sur la préparation de
notre pays pour affronter un scénario de
ce type qu'on n'imaginait pas et encore
quelques mois
je pense que on ne peut pas l'imaginer
non plus ceci étant le rôle de l'état
c'est effectivement dans d'anticiper
simplement les pastis diodes
malheureusement sont pas la réponse une
attaque nucléaire c'est d'une autre
c'est d'une autre nature
donc aujourd'hui mais les informations
que donne le ministre on l'est on les
entend mais bon c'est pas cool vous êtes
enfermé d'ailleurs en tant que chef de
parti sur ces sujets là absolument aucun
sens car il est par exemple je pense
qu'à minima il pourra y avoir
effectivement des réunions d'information
mais vous savez c'est là c'est la macro
knees président de la république seul
décide de tout donc aucun aucun lien
avec 10 avec le président de la
république pas plus qu'avec le premier
ministre les membres du gouvernement
d'ailleurs on sait que les élections
sont un moment où l'on peut craindre des
ingérences en dans le cadre d'un conflit
naturellement par l'ue et l'ukraine
contre la russie qui est assez allant
sur les cyberattaques est ce que en tant
que responsable de parti vous avez pris
des mesures particulières
vous protège in a été oui parce que en
dehors du conflit et de la guerre en
ukraine on est toujours les partis
politiques sont toujours la cible des
attaques
je pense pas au jeu objectivement je ne
pense pas on l'est on l'était beaucoup
il ya un an
six mois le sentiment qu'on l'ait plutôt
moins aujourd'hui mais
tout le monde est la cible d'attaqués
savez ce qu'on dit ce que dit souvent
les experts dans ce domaine les seuls
qui ne sont pas les cibles d'attaqués et
ceux qui ne les connaissent pas mais pas
de précautions particulières de la part
de votre parti pendant cette période
électorale aujourd'hui non pas
particulièrement pas plus que deux en
tout cas pendant tout le début de la
campagne valérie pécresse s'est posée
comme seul capable de battre emmanuel
macron elle n'est plus jamais dans les
sondages qualifié pour le second tour le
vote utile ça n'est plus valérie
pécresse pour les électeurs de droite si
je pense que si simplement l'on verra
vous savez le rendez vous c'est le soir
du premier tour
rappelez vous au moment des élections
régionales
dans les 13 régions de france le front
national était surcoté de 5 à 15 points
on était nous sous côté quasiment
d'autant pas tout à fait parce que
c'était reparti aussi sur les autres
partis donc le seul rendez vous qui
compte c'est celui du premier tour c'est
pour ça que nous sommes dans un moment
où tout et tout est possible dit aux
électeurs potentiels dernière qui
pourrait se dire bon bah il faut voter
utile à droite je peux voter emmanuel
macron par exemple voter utile à droite
c'est voter valérie pécresse parce que
valérie pécresse a cette capacité ses
qualités qu'elle a démontré à la tête de
l'as de la plus grande collectivité
d'europe c'est qu'elle sait faire le
président de la république qui est un
bilan qu'il 0 il ya aucune réforme qui a
été porté les engagements qu'ils avaient
pris valérie pécresse il ya six ans dans
son mandat régional puisque c'est celui
là qu'elle a exercé jusqu'à maintenant
ont tous été tenus macron aucun été
tenus mais qu'est-ce que tu as comme ces
sondages christian jacob qu'est ce
qu'ils racontent ya une dynamique en ce
moment en faveur de la campagne de
valérie pécresse vous sentez vraiment
une dynamique sur le terrain 500 il ya
une photo les sondages c'est une
photographie un moment donné de la même
façon qu'on l'avait pour les régionales
il y avait une photographie de 34,90 les
sondages ne sont pas faux simplement la
faute aux allées au moment donné et ce
qui compte c'est le rendez vous vous
savez c'est comme une course comme un
marathon vous avez des gens qui tombent
au 20e d'auto 30e d'auto 35e ce qui
compte c'est d'être à l'arrivée et
aujourd'hui l'art vl n'ai pas joué et
c'est en ce moment que ça se joue
valérie al'avantage de la crédibilité de
l'expérience la compétence de la
ténacité aussi parce que l'enfant comme
tous les jours facile à peu près je
pense un peu plus objectivement je pense
un peu plus pourquoi
parce qu'elle est la cible à la fois des
extrêmes et du pouvoir mac rognant
puisque le seul risque pour emmanuel
macron c'est un deuxième tour avec
valérie pécresse et d'ailleurs depuis le
début la stratégie de d'emmanuel mâcon
c'est de faire monter les extrêmes
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche il
a mobilisé toute son énergie là-dessus
en ne faisant pas campagne en cherchant
à faire l'impasse en ayant refusant de
rendre des comptes quand on dit souvent
que c'est une élection ça se gagne ce
non pas sur un bilan sur un projet mais
une réélection j'étais maire quand vous
êtes maire vous représentez à votre
élection il faut rendre des comptes sur
ce qui a été fait or là c'est la gestion
à dire la plus catastrophique mais pas
loin de ces dernières années des
dépenses publiques qui explose beaucoup
plus vite que sous françois hollande qui
était quand même pas une référence en
matière de gestion de deniers publics
avec une petite crise non avant la crise
qu vide avant la crise que vit de la
moyenne des dépenses publiques sous
françois hollande s'était 1,4 pour cent
par an avec emmanuel macron edouard
philippe ses 2,6 avant la crise qu vite
donc on explose les dépenses publiques
quand on explose les dépenses publiques
ont créé du déficit on crée de la dette
et la dette c'est de l'impro premier
gouvernement depuis 40 ans qui est
incapable de faire une réforme des
retraites là aussi même hollande avait
réussi à faire une lettre à m la
prochaine fois wemhoff attendait dire je
n'ai absolument rien fait j'étais dans
la capacité et parfois dans dans la
compétence à mener une réforme mais bien
les voir on rase gratis dans un mois
vous ne croyez pas ces se fiche du monde
non ce qu'est ce qu'il a fait son
quinquennat il ya eu trois ans avant
lincot vide tous les gouvernements
réformer les retraites lui non seulement
réforme pas les retraites mais baisse
des pensions des retraités parce que
l'augmentation de la csg c'est bien une
baisse des pensions on les retraites
doit encore démontrer valérie pécresse
est ce cas là encore quelque chose à
démontrer d'ici au vote du premier tour
devraient continuer sur la ligne qui est
la sienne celle de la ténacité
celle aussi qui consiste développé à
présenter son
quatre jours a toujours incarné quoi
pour incarner un vrai changement c'est à
dire la nécessité de réformer notre pays
en matière de sécurité là aussi et
chaque de macron les chiffres de la
sécurité explose 30% de plus et
violences sur personne pour prendre que
ce chiffre en matière d'insécurité
l'incapacité qu'il a eu à l'incarner la
réduction des dépenses publiques oui il
ya six ans lorsque valérie pécresse
prend la présidence de la région
ile-de-france à l'annonce moins 10% de
baisse des dépenses de fonctionnement
six ans après il ya moins 10% des
dépenses de fonctionnement et elles
réinvestissent d'air qu'elle engage cet
argent dans l'investissement macron il a
pris tous les engagements rien est au
rendez vous rien est le bilan est de
zéro et les héros mais il est à 30 dans
les sondages oui mais le bilan les héros
et donc c'est pour ça que ça veut dire
que les français qui lui font encore
confiance aujourd'hui se trompent parce
qu'ils sont dans ce moment qui est qui
et celui d'abord la guerre on vit bas
vous le voyez sur vos images au rythme
des saint pierre qui génère énormément
énormément l'inquiétude est donc dans
cette période de stress et d'inquiétude
profonde et bien on se raccroche à celui
qui aujourd'hui je l'étais en effet au
moment du vote moi je reste à la fois
confiant et déterminé surtout penser
christian jacob que la légitimité du
prochain président peut se poser s'il
n'y a pas de campagne j'entends
j'utilise à dessein le mot légitimité
puisque c'est un mot qui a été utilisé
il ya quelques jours par gérard larcher
qui a beaucoup fait parler de la part du
président du sénat la raison il a raison
il a raison on ne peut pas faire
l'impasse
on a fait l'impasse disons le il ya cinq
ans il ya cinq ans avec le deuxième tour
avec le le front national y l'impasse
sur ce débat démocratique on ne peut pas
pendant dix ans
faire l'impasse d'un débat démocratique
et donc il y à la nécessité aujourd'hui
d'avoir cet échange et ce débat ce n'est
pas le simulacre de rencontre avec les
français là aussi vous avez le président
de la république qui d'abord maintenant
vous avez noté parle de lui à la
troisième personne le président pense
que le candidat dit que ça devient
hallucinant la rencontre avec les
français c'est 200 personnes filtré
choisi avant si ou l'elysée va même
jusqu'à rédiger les questions qu'elles
sont prêtés légitimité tout ça veut dire
que s'il est élu le 24 avril prochain
vous considérez vous en tant que chef de
parti qui n'est pas légitime pour
conduire aux affaires du pays ça veut
dire quand on parle de légitimité ça
veut dire que le débat qui n'a pas lieu
là où il n'y a pas de débat démocratique
et bien il y à des risques dans la rue
parce que les français ont la décision
besoin d'avoir un choix clair c'est à
dire sur les réformes qui sont
nécessaires comment elles seront faits
il suffit pas de le dire c'est à dire ça
n'est pas du maquereau dans le texte où
on annonce tout ce qui a été incapable
de faire pendant cinq ans mais on va
tout faire en un mois christian jacob
est pareil dans votre parti certains
pensent déjà à la presse lapret des
fêtes et la bataille des législatives
moi je pense à la preuve victoire
vraiment
rien n'est joué aujourd'hui rien n'est
joué aujourd'hui si vous savez il ya la
nécessité et c'est notre rôle de
mobiliser notre électorat en rappelant
qu effectivement rien n'est joué que
valérie pécresse a cette capacité de
faire et donc c'est la mobilisation à
200 ou à 300% une question quand même
sur les législatives est ce que c'est un
problème pour vous que le vote
intervienne 63 jours après la
présidentielle contre 49 en 2017 il
paraît que c'est un problème pour le
chef de l'état qui pourrait y avoir une
dissolution c'est des choses qu'on a
entendues est ce que ce serait un sujet
pour vous d'abord c'est son choix à lui
c'est lui qui a décidé de soldates c'est
pas nous qui lavons des simples alors
une fois de plus il annonce quelque
chose il va vouloir faire le contraire
on a tellement l'habitude avec macron
vous savez le jour où il aura la
cohérent la cohérence ou une ligne qui
tiendra vous nouerez inviterez pour
qu'on en parle je voudrais simplement
dire si vous allez partir aussi pareil
vous avez partir cet été du parti et à
l'air oh oui je sais pas c'est pas un
scoop j'avais toujours annonce est comme
ma mission se termine après les
élections législatives mais d'ici là il
y aura les législatives a cool merci
beaucoup d'avoir été mon invité ce matin
une fois votre cette interview podcast
on vous le souhaitez sur france télé